real-time schema Discovery so a little
bit of a disclaimer here is that uh when
I first started working on this talk
um was it like a month ago or so uh I
was hot off the heels of uh basically
being really stoked about like how we
did all this and it was really really
fast and uh it was well it's it took a
lot of a lot of work to actually
implement it and stuff and I was really
happy about it and I really wanted to
talk about it and show it to the World
um and then the closer this conference
came the more I realized it like well
probably shouldn't do this like so this
talk has turned into like at first it
was like look at this this is so
freaking awesome and it's turned into uh
maybe you shouldn't do this and this is
the result of uh like what happens if
you do have to do this and then what is
probably a better alternative than doing
this
um so anyway that's what you're gonna
get so let's get going with this
um let me use arrows okay the most
important slide actually it's about me
uh me myself and I I am Daniel
um I am the CTO and co-founder for
streamdoll and we're basically like a
think of it as like a data dog for
streaming so
I do like all kinds of uh anomaly
detection monitoring of the actual data
so like not metrics right there's the
data itself uh that's on the bus so but
prior to that I did a ton of time in
software and systems and when I say
systems I mean like uh was actually in
data centers for like 10 plus years
doing Integrations engineering so lots
of super weird stuff like uh working
with generators and uh
SNMP integration all kinds of just weird
weird stuff and it is great as a result
of that so
um
for the past 10 years I've been writing
mostly back-end code I do go primarily
it's pretty sweet
um and uh generally speaking I mostly
talk about event driven stuff and lots
of event sourcing and all kinds of just
generally fairly complex distributed
system architectures and stuff that's
kind of like my jam but the good news is
that you don't have to listen to that
nonsense a day I am going to be talking
about schemas instead and usually I talk
about the about acing stuff and
fun story fun fact is that I am from
Portland Oregon right now but I'm
originally was born and raised in Riga
Latvia and you know
latvians yeah and whatever anyway
um and previous to that I was yeah at
New Relic uh Community digital ocean
Envision uh a few other companies
um that may be semi-recognizable at
least so basically focus on a lot of
high throughput and stuff so
all right so uh why are we even talking
about uh schema Discovery in the first
place if I know how to push buttons uh
well we need to establish a little bit
of context for all this in the first
place so so let's go with that so
everybody probably knows what a schema
is but let's just get that out there so
it's predefined and agreed upon
structure and layout for data right
makes sense nothing too terribly
difficult so uh why is it actually
important well uh the data is going to
be used by many teams and everyone needs
access to this data and the thing is
that uh well of course data Engineers
need access to the data that's pretty
obvious you're going to build uh you can
use it for machine learning or for
various other analytics purposes and so
on but the thing is as we're moving
further and further it's not just the
data Engineers who care about this
there's going to be several other teams
that are going to care about this stuff
too like uh as a company evolves more
than likely the result the artifact of
this data especially if it's well
defined in the first place the it's
going to be consumed by developers right
and uh if you go further it's also going
to be probably consumed by platform and
devops folks as well because that's the
source of Truth potentially right so
establishing a schema then is kind of
like an important thing because it's not
just you that actually will care about
it in the first place right so
well what happens without a schema well
um the most obvious one is there's going
to be incidents and outages like when
there's no schema well nobody knows what
happened upstream and downstream gets
affected right uh pretty sensible thing
I mean uh that this happens all the time
non-stop that somebody changes something
and somebody gets affected by it as well
so it is the most obvious one uh I think
a horrible part of this is of course is
duplicate duplicated effort right
because uh everyone is going to have
their own idea of what it means you know
to sanitize and to normalize data
everyone's going to do it kind of
differently and then well where do you
who do you trust in the first place that
sort of thing
um it's it's just a just generally well
a wasted time right that's all it is
ultimately and it all spawns from the
fact that well there is no schema in the
first place so uh put in some schema
examples and stuff but like uh the most
obvious one is like just Json
um there are some standards out there
right like there's like Cloud events and
there's Json schema as well Cloud events
is uh uh it's really geared towards uh
not really towards data engineering but
it totally could be as well it would be
totally fine the all the stuff that you
see here which is like metadata it's uh
honestly it's not as important as simply
the thing which talks about type and
data the type is going to you know
indicate what is actually going to be
inside the data right
um oh man that's tiny but anyways
there's Avro if you're doing Java then
Avro is fantastic idea all together
because it's been so established forever
and ever already but it is a binary
encoding ultimately which is super
awesome and it's strongly typed has all
the Primitives has complex types as well
yada yada
um it's
quite okay uh specifically if you're in
Java if in other languages like yeah so
it's okay
um but if you're in other languages
um if you're in well anything if you and
if you don't care about it being Java
specific well and then there's probably
protobuf um and protobuf is like kind of
the the latest iteration of uh from
Google right uh to basically simplify
schemas and formats essentially
um but it has the same thing it has all
the Primitives has enums has complex
types you can reference complex types
from different places
uh it has yeah arrays maps all that sort
of stuff
um pretty obvious cool so the conclusion
from all this is is that having the
schema is like a really foundational
component
um it's a really important piece really
right so um and if you don't have a
schema well there's going to be tons of
wasted engineering effort and uh
ultimately there's going to be outages
right like it's just things are going to
there's going to be some sort of
incidents in the first place this
happens all the time non-stop even and
that's the thing that like it already
happens with schemas as well but the the
volume of them is going to be
dramatically smaller if there is
actually at least a schema
um so what we ultimately want is like to
be able to resolve this thing and we're
getting to this the point this is still
the context by the way
um but we're almost there at the end so
of the context so you want to define a
schema right
um but there's a problem here is that uh
if you just Define a schema if you're
just a team there's still no source of
truth right like as in team a may have
defined a schema that's fantastic but uh
Team B doesn't actually know about the
schema and they're still going to do
their own thing cool so uh the step two
would be that you would establish like a
schema update process right and you
would say you would basically send out a
company email or something like an all
slack message and there's a bunch of
Architects that decide that like oh
we're gonna do uh we're gonna do schemas
this way
um but uh there's still a possibility
that somebody's not going to follow it
all right it's not like this massive uh
uh you haven't maybe realized yet that
it requires a serious like seriously
wide adoption across the entire organ
it's a really really like difficult
thing to do in the first place
especially if you have a super large org
and here's the final part of the context
this is a this is how you might arrive
at the conclusion that like you know
what we need is a real-time schema
Discovery all right so in other words
instead of having to go through all this
stuff of establishing uh well
establishing a protobook schema or an
Avro schema or whatever schema it
doesn't matter flat buffer or something
whatever you end up using even Thrift
let's say you decide like oh it's just
going to be so much easier to just do a
real-time like real-time scheme of
discovery
well and that's how we're here
um there's a reason why there's a smiley
face with a little teardrop there is uh
because actually it's not just 17 steps
it could be like I don't know 65 steps
really or like maybe 122.
um so I will do a little bit of context
here like so like our company
um the thing that we do is we ingest a
ton of data and uh the first thing that
we did like was we have first class
protobuf support first class Avro Thrift
blah blah all these awesome formats
they're all fantastic all right
um but it means it it's really easy for
us to build a system for that because
basically they're saying like hey you
give us your you know give us your
schemas and we know exactly how to
decode the stream then
um like you know of whatever events that
you're sending us uh the reality of it
though is that uh there's like a really
tiny percentage of people that are
actually doing protobuf like as a first
class thing people are using Json it
makes sense Json is super easy so so we
couldn't have a platform that is not
able to accept Json that is ridiculous
right like so uh we being a bunch of
software Engineers just being like
what's the big deal like we're just
gonna write this like I know how to
write an ASD bar so it's not a big deal
I could do this
um so we did and uh
it's not great it's it's actually pretty
hard like it was really really difficult
and especially when we're talking about
real time so what we're going to go
through is kind of like a distilled um
almost step by step skipping some steps
uh process of what it actually took us
to to do this sort of a thing so uh
we're gonna go through that so let's go
how do you actually do this well uh the
first thing is going to be that you're
going to need to determine and nominate
some sort of a source of truth right of
where all your data is at
um so that doesn't mean that like oh you
need to figure out like you need to say
um the these I don't know these mail
servers or FTP servers and so on these
are the sources of truth no they're not
they're they're just sources of data but
ultimately your source of truth you're
just going to pack it all into Kafka
probably and then from there you're
going to do the whole entire process
right like a re-encoding the data where
like sanitizing and normalizing it and
finally you actually uh create you know
you know you encode all this stuff so
cool so you're establishing the source
of truth it's that's not really terribly
hard especially if it's a smaller org
not really a big deal
um okay next uh then you're gonna write
a service that will will consume from
Kafka well
everyone's probably done that if you
write back in code it's not that big of
a deal you just write a service whatever
this is nothing really uh pretty simple
then it gets a little trickier then
you're gonna decide okay like okay now
we need to parse Json in the first place
well Parson Json and accessing different
parts it's not really terribly difficult
like there are plenty of libraries in
every single language that are able to
parse Json fairly quickly but all of a
sudden you'll start like paying
attention to like oh well so we use go
so for go we for instance looked at like
G Json how fast does that actually parse
Json in the first place for instance you
do not like the way you parse the type
of libraries that you would choose would
have you'd want to read the source code
of how they actually do it in the first
place you would want to for instance
have character by character like reads
instead of them actually building an
entire AST tree what they think it
should be like right so you're basically
going to start paying attention to these
sort of things and you're going to start
paying attention to Performance of
things in the first place so this part
already is kind of rough and ultimately
the artifact here is you need to come up
with some sort of a schema format right
something that is going to Define that
like this Json contains uh you know this
and this field it has this type blah
blah and you want it to be in something
that's probably neutral like language
neutral so maybe you would choose
parquet parquet does not actually have a
direct output of what it's supposed to
look like so you're going to have to
come up with that too of what it
actually is going to be represented at
because you're going to want to save it
somewhere probably right like the state
of what does the schema of this data
come in as so
all right so um at that point you're
we're all very smart and we all work
with distributed systems then you're
gonna have a situation that you have
this service and uh you're going to be
interesting data from all over the place
um You probably have a bunch of services
that are horizontally scaled you have
like you know five six ten replicas of
this thing everybody gets basically
their own vision of what something looks
like
um so think of it as this think of it as
like one service receives something that
says age 13 that's an integer and all of
a sudden another service receives like
at the same exact moment let's just say
well
within milliseconds or whatever
nanoseconds receives another event and
that one says age 13 in quotes and
that's a ginormous problem right in the
first place because that means that
there's a conflict so now you need to
figure out conflict resolution and that
right there is going to be horrible
because what we're talking about we're
not talking about a single service doing
conflict resolution we're talking about
just like it needs to be a distributed
conflict resolution process right so
you're going to more than likely create
some sort of an election process you're
going to have services that actually
will basically send out this is what we
think is like you know there's the real
schema then somebody else is going to
say well I think it's like this and then
you need to basically have something
that will say well actually it's both of
those you know and it needs to be fast
and it needs to happen like if we're
talking about real time that a real time
basically kind of falls apart after one
second right
um so it has to be sub second and uh if
you're dealing with any sort of high
throughput so let's say like
100 messages even a second it's not even
a high throughput but let's just say
that uh you'd probably want to generally
batch stuff like you would probably want
to batch at least for a couple of
seconds because otherwise you're just
gonna have so much chatter and stuff for
like for all the schema election stuff
um anyways yeah so you're going to go
through all that you're going to
implement this thing and it's going to
be pretty rough
um I put in learning raft in there so uh
RAF being a consensus protocol or
consistent consensus algorithm for
distributed systems so more than likely
you'd use that but maybe you know I
don't know if you know member list or
something and you know gossip as well
and you know some other things but point
is like
probably a good idea for you to be like
a distributed systems nerd like there's
no other way around this really you're
going to have to figure out how to do
this sort of a thing and it's going to
be rough
um so from all those other things that
were above I mean writing in AST parts
for this point like for Json it's not
that big of a deal like this part is
going to be tough like for sure
um
so oh yeah there's the service of course
that you're going to write and now you
have you know the library that you wrote
then you can put it into a distributed
service that also needs to be
distributed as well you don't want to
just have a single point of failure so
at that point when you have you know if
you have it like a distributed election
service then that means that you'd
probably need to have some sort of a way
to elect one of those nodes as a leader
so now you have leader election as well
that you need to start thinking about
um
so um oh what do you do with
unresolvable conflicts so the the the
scenario that I presented where you have
uh age that everybody thinks is supposed
to be an integer but now it actually is
a string well that's a unresolvable
conflict so that means that you're
probably going to have to come up with
some sort of a way to basically create a
dead letter Q
um dead letter Q's besides just
basically throwing stuff to the side
um since this is supposed to be a
real-time like schema Discovery service
or a process really you probably want to
have like a really legit dlq process as
well so more than likely you're going to
instrument and create that entire thing
it's a literally a completely separate
project altogether right
um and uh yeah throughout this whole
entire process you're I I would
guarantee it you're going to patent
something like so you're going to
discover something that is so
ridiculously hard
um that you're going to end up patenting
something and uh we did that we did
exactly that we came to the conclusion
like well the way we do schema elections
and stuff uh it's pretty intense like we
like I don't read like white papers but
I had to but like for this thing I
actually had to like learn Raph properly
like what happens under the covers for
this thing and that it's just a lot
um and actually as I was writing this
list this was the point in time when I
was like I think this talk is kind of
going to a different direction like
instead of being like wow this is so
awesome everybody should do this no it's
like it's not a good idea really
um so um yeah we did all this and uh
here's the here's the thing is that uh
tons of other people have done it as
well and uh
sorry about that it looks weird but
whatever like you get it snowflake is
there and data bricks is there and
everybody's there including even us as
well
um but there's a little tiny thing here
is that uh uh so first off this is
schema inference that's really the
synonym like like it's synonymous with
that um is it schema inference and uh if
you search for schema inference across
all these uh across all these vendors
they all support it they all mention the
schema inference but the thing is every
single one of them have edge cases
they're all over the place in some cases
The Edge case is horrible like uh we
won't name any names but when data comes
in and it has some sort of an
unresolvable conflict on schemas things
just stop and uh that's when you have
potentially an outage and yada yada and
all that sort of stuff and uh here's the
thing
um I can't really talk about uh everyone
but uh I assume uh everyone had a pretty
rough time with this
um and the reason those edge cases exist
is because uh there's just so many of
them there's just tons and tons of them
and uh based like you're basically
choosing just like uh with the cap
theorem if anybody's familiar with that
like uh you have to choose really two
out of that
um so anyway uh in our case I can't like
speak up speak to what it was like for
AWS or for you know snowflake or
something like that like uh to figure
out uh what to do uh scheme inference
but for us we're a scrappy little
startup we had uh 11
folks in our at our company and uh all
of our all of our Engineers are
principal Engineers every single one of
them and uh initially when we started
this uh yeah it took us about six months
to actually build this thing uh with two
people I think and uh then later on it
took us about whatever it says there but
it took us about another four months to
get it into prod and we thought like ah
this is good everything is working great
um and then after that uh it took us
another three months to basically deal
with the Fallout of what happened when
we were like yeah this is good like it's
totally working in prod because it's
kind of working abroad but not really
like uh there's like customers would
complain about random things it was just
uh honestly it was pretty huge mess
altogether so
um and then since then this is still a
reality right now
um more than likely this will happen
again in like uh next month there's
going to be somebody messaging us saying
that like there's this weird thing I
don't see the this event in here and
then we'll probably go through like
basically a week of troubleshooting
being trying to prove this person wrong
and then realizing that like well no
never mind this is a bug like this still
sucks like this is something with our
distribute like you know with our
process uh of like election process
maybe some messages got dropped
somewhere that's where it's just uh yeah
it's a big old thing so the reality of
that right is like I just wanted to put
it down into numbers and stuff is that
uh so two principal level Engineers uh a
little over a year uh let's say minimum
200k a year salary
um for both of them so uh it's gonna get
kind of expensive and then there's going
to be probably at least two senior level
engineers
we're going to be working on this stuff
for about let's say like nicely let's
say eight hours you know per month
um in this case uh just you know ongoing
support just troubleshooting things
trying to figure out like what went
wrong ultimately the principal Engineers
probably get called into this as well
again
uh somebody who actually knows how this
was implemented in the first place to
prove something and so on so basically
it's just like it's a ton of effort into
something that you already think is
great like uh and it's I mean you have
patent Sports so how could it not be
great
um so anyway
the end of the end result really is
right is that the UE spent well about
500k or so on this entire Endeavor of
trying to support real-time schema
Discovery
um and since then this is just Theory
really but I think like it's probably
somewhere around like 40K a year that
we're spending on this uh because I mean
it literally happened like two days ago
like we had a message from a customer uh
that basically said that there's some
sort of uh some data that they didn't
expect to see was actually there and
then we had to prove that like well
that's actually totally normal and it's
not normal no like the data shouldn't
even even been there it should have just
been dropped in the first place so all
kinds of weird stuff like that happens
all the time so
I guess yeah the the point of this is
that um
no matter how cool it is and no matter
how great you think you are especially
if you're like a software developer at
least got like serious chops and you're
not afraid of digging into like really
really complex problems uh you still
shouldn't do it probably
um but it is a probably because there
are some cases where you still need to
do it but uh if you end up deciding that
this is a thing that you absolutely must
do like well it's a different
conversation we should probably just
talk about it and like I'll be more than
happy to provide whatever you need for
this thing and try to dissuade you
because it's it's really bad so um I
guess yeah uh the instead you can go
around all this and you can basically
skip all this and just say if there's a
choice rather right
um that you can basically establish uh
establish a schema and uh when I first
wrote like specifically this slide I was
just like uh I don't know how people are
going to take this
um you know trying to establish like a
proper foundational schema but here's
the thing like two days ago we had Chad
who talked about data quality and guess
what was the first thing on that slide
it was a schema and uh that made me
really really happy because uh now I'm
able to say like yeah you should
establish a schema there are other
people that are way better than me that
have already said the same thing so
here we are talking about protobuf and
establishing a schema so that's what
we're gonna do
um so for those uh has anybody use
protobuf like
all right okay all right so some folks
so never mind all you nerds um we're
going to focus on everybody else who
hasn't done photobuff in the first place
so
um yeah so protobufs right are Google's
uh language neutral platform neutral
extensible mechanism for serializing so
encoding decoding structured data
basically like XML it's not crappy
um sorry if anybody's using XML
that's yeah that's your situation I'm
sorry
um but it's basically like that right
and it's structured and ultimately when
you encode it
um it's it turns into binary and it's
really fast as a result of that it's
much smaller uh there's tons of benefits
to it right
um and the thing is it's totally doable
it's very readable in general like so
the example right there is on the right
where like there's a base message and
the base message includes you know it
has like an action that's a string could
be an enum or something like that as
well then it has a complex type which is
a sub command and the sub command is
defined right right on top right so it's
a pretty straightforward so um
and in general with protobuf what you do
is uh you compile it quote unquote but
really I mean you're not really
compiling anything because uh you're
really just generating code that's all
it is like you're basically taking those
photos and you're going to generate a
bunch of code in whatever language you
use right like whatever part part uh
whatever stack you have so whether it's
like Java or typescript or golang or
whatever you would just basically run
this tool called proto-c that is going
to compile the the protos like which
basically contain all your definitions
and the artifact that it's going to
create are going to be a bunch of pb.go
or Java files and so on
um so the which will contain uh
basically the data structures right the
representative of the protobufs so of
your probable schemas in this case I
have uh Docker like I'm just basically
running the compiler the proto-c
compiler through Docker in the first
place
um it's kind of old like this is a super
old screenshot in the first place but uh
this is generally the generally what
you're probably going to do especially
like if you're doing in like Ci or
something like that so
um cool and yeah the example right here
is of uh well what does this actually
look like all right so uh on the left
you have the actual protocol definition
the same one we saw before and on the
right are the structs that it generates
it will generate all kinds of access for
methods and all kinds of extra stuff in
there as well but the meat and potatoes
here is uh are those two structs
essentially that's that's what you're
after is to have a very clear defined
path right like I said what this
protobuf is actually supposed to be in
there
um well that said you're still going to
need like if you want to do some sort of
semantic validation that's that's a
separate thing altogether but at least
at this point you already have some sort
of validation which is it is impossible
to even get into that situation where
something came in that's a string and
now it's becoming an end there's
literally no way for that to be even
happen right like uh and that's that's
that's the power really of of choosing
something like protobuf so
um and the general flow for this really
right is going to be that's the thing
like people just throw out stuff and
they say like ah let's just do this just
do replays like you don't know how but
anyway so with the protobuf stuff
um the thing that's worked for us and
I've done protoba for past I don't know
how many years now probably like 10
years or so
and it has always worked really well
when you just simply put the protobuf
definitions or the protos inside of
GitHub repo that's it and then
everything happens from the GitHub repo
right uh meaning that uh let's see so
your repo is ultimately going to be
governed by essentially all the
stakeholders right so people who are who
care about Proto or they don't have to
care about protobuf they have to care
about the organization in general they
have some sort of a stake in the org
right so whether they have a service or
whether you're a data engineer that
cares about the Kafka that is actually
this data is going through and so on
you're going to basically just watch
this repo just like any other repo that
you would have in the first place right
you would just basically watch it and
see the changes are happening in there
right
um
the schema changes would be proposed via
PR nothing super crazy or anything just
a PR and you will notice it and you know
you're like well this looks okay moving
on that's it
um
and once it's all merged well GitHub
usually the easiest thing is like right
is to just to basically set up some sort
of a notification action or something
like that and GitHub that basically will
push maybe I don't know an email pager
Duty slack something just it'll push
something to tell everyone like hey
something happened here it's a big deal
and basically that notifies all the
consumers and producers to know that
like uh like again we're talking about
stakeholder producers and consumers that
they need to update their services that
like some new version of like of the
protobuf schemas have like uh come out
right
um and then
the stakeholders see the scheme updates
uh uh the schema update notifications
and they're going to update all their
components and stuff right uh it is uh
really important to note that
um part of this entire PR process is to
not allow backwards breaking uh
basically incompatible changes and the
thing is that that sounds super complex
but it's totally not because it just
means that you're looking for the color
red meaning that you do not delete stuff
that's it that's all you do you just do
not delete stuff ever from protabove and
if you see something red you don't have
to be like a hardcore like architect to
be like no no no like you can't like you
could just be a ding dong who's just
like ah
this does not look right so anyway
um it's an opportunity to look very
smart so anyway
um so that's what you're gonna do and
you're going to want to deploy your
consumers first
um I think that that's pretty obvious
probably is but it's a basically if you
would deploy producers first there's a
chance that your consumers do not have
updated schemas yet so they're going to
basically drop data that's all it is
right so if your producers are encoding
something and adding some sort of fields
that your consumers are not aware of
well it's going to work but it's just
simply going to be like this is gone it
doesn't exist so basically you do your
consumers first then you do your
producers uh you can come up with
several ways to like announce and say
like consumers are done right like that
you've finished this process so
um cool producer deployed with new
schema obviously yeah so after after
consumers so and the actual uh how does
this all look in practice really is that
uh what you get is that all the services
are ultimately using a common schema
everywhere right so it doesn't matter
that it's a a data engineering specific
service or a platform service or like
some devops service that is doing
something somewhere you don't care like
everybody is using the same exact thing
and that's awesome it's super great
because like uh maybe at some point in
time some devops person is going to care
about like you know something that is
usually would just you know be cared
about only by a data engineer right that
sort of thing so
um
and this makes sense right this is just
a general flow is that the services are
going to encode all the Ingress data so
that means that like they're also going
to do all the normalization sanitation
blah blah sanitization and ultimately
they're going to encode that stuff in
protobuf so basically the final artifact
which is basically everything starts
from here
is protobuf it's like an encoded
protobuf piece of data that is sitting
on Kafka or whatever whatever you're
using whether it's rabbitmq or something
um
same thing yeah Services yeah so
Services emit all the data to a data bus
um call it a data bus just because I
mean I look at like Kafka Pulsar those
sort of things is like it's essentially
like a distributed buffer really
um you know dumped to completely take it
down to the lowest possible level that's
really what it is so
um yeah uh and everybody obviously knows
the scheme already because there's it's
a common schema so all the consumers
know exactly what they're getting
there's no guesswork involved there's
essentially a type switch where you're
going to be like what type of message is
this and there's going to be an enum
inside the Proto boat that says like oh
this is a billing message you know that
sort of thing so everybody knows exactly
what to do there's no question about you
know that thing where you go to I don't
know some person that has some esoteric
knowledge that's like you know from six
years ago uh about a field and that's
how you decide that like oh this is a
this is a really important message
because it's 46. like you know all that
sort of stuff has been established and
just thrown away it's like it's real
like everybody can figure this out and
you don't need you know John or Lizzy to
figure this sort of a thing out
um so uh yeah consumers of course yeah
they do stuff with the actual decoded
data but ultimately uh the benefits of
this whole entire thing that we've gone
through is that uh oh there's a single
source of truth right uh everybody knows
exactly where stuff is at and they do
not need to hunt down the actual service
owner or uh to serve the producer or the
consumer you literally just simply look
at uh you'll just look at the schemas
themselves and they're very human
readable it's not it's better than I
think than even yaml or something right
because it's so incredibly readable in
the first place so
um there's no guesswork around the
structure of the data uh having uh been
in plenty of places where I've had to
write a service and they're like oh just
write this billing service and I have
absolutely no idea of what it actually
looks like and what it means is tapping
into a data stream of some sort reading
for a little bit and seeing like ah oh
they're not filling that part out so
like or whatever and just saying like I
think this is roughly right
um and more than likely it's not going
to be right like you're going to you're
basically creating a bunch of throwaway
code right and uh this is one way how
you say like man you don't need to do
any of that so
um
don't need for normalization and I mean
by that like that during the encode
process of yeah there's going to be
normalization and sanitation uh
sanitization but the thing is that like
after that there's going to be none of
that and there's only one singular place
where it all happens right
um because you're just basically you've
come up with a common way to do this
um there's a cost reduction that is
probably kind of a duh but uh I mean
you're dealing with binary encode like
binary data so naturally all those
little
quoties and uh you know whatever sort of
other
little braces you know all that sort of
stuff it's all gone it doesn't exist
there's not even like uh like in
protobuf you just have integers for
index numbers that's it like one through
whatever ten thousand or ninety nine
thousand I don't know some huge number
in any case so uh and the the comparison
right is ginormous uh I think at minimum
it's like a 75 reduction in size of the
actual payloads and that well not just
the Payless but the entire event so and
that has massive ramifications not just
in terms of like oh man you're going to
use way less memory but it's going to be
the platform folks in this case we're
probably going to say thanks because all
of a sudden your egress costs are going
to be way way lower right because it's
all sitting on in protobuf so
um
there's going to be less bugs I mean
that's kind of an obvious because uh you
know what to fill out you cannot fill
out something that's not there it's
literally like you can't even specify it
and it's literally your code is not
going to compile you know that sort of
thing
um but most importantly I think you're
establishing a really solid foundation
for the future right uh I think that
that is the piece that Chad was talking
about as well is that uh you are
establishing a way it's not just uh
you're dealing with your problem at that
point in time you are really making a
massive decision for the entire org and
basically setting it up for success for
later so it's not just a data problem
and we're like it's not just an SRE
problem or whatever uh security pro
everybody gets access to this and they
can do uh you know they know what to do
with this data and you don't have to
hold any hands right so uh so that's why
yeah I think it's a really solid
beginning to this entire thing so DIY
schema Discovery uh and distributed
systems yeah it's terribly hard it's
insanely hard
um and obviously the like well you'll
probably guess and see that like the
hardest part of all this is uh this is
conflict resolution it's totally that
it's because you need uh because you can
have conflicts that are uh that are
resolvable and then there's conflicts
that are not resolvable
um and you need to do it fast and you
need to do it in real time and uh yeah
there's so many like you know tiny
little edge cases around this entire
thing uh I'm pretty sure we're nowhere
close to actually getting like getting
it right it's it's pretty good but it
still happens like all the time that
something weird just happens
um like for instance I'll give you an
example that uh like what happens like a
quick tiny little example like what
happens if uh this is the first time
you've ever seen data from this you know
from this uh source of Truth or whatever
like ever and uh so meaning you don't
have a like a schema established at all
this is like completely blank slate you
know nothing and all of a sudden you get
this blast like just of like let's say a
hundred messages on one service and 100
messages on another service that came
through a load balancer or something
like that
and both of them are conflicting which
one do you pick like which one is the
okay one obviously one of them is okay
um so because of that you're going to
need some form of conflict resolution in
the first place you're going to need to
like dlq's on that sort of thing and you
need to basically weigh what is more
important all of a sudden you're going
to start looking at like well what looks
like more important data you know uh
this is going to be all kinds of things
in that so um yeah it's a massive time
sync but um
it's truly necessary only if you have to
deal with semi-structured data like Json
right or yaml like anything that is
semi-structured right it's not binary
all right
um
and I think that in general this time
instead of trying to go and and discuss
even the discussion of like I mean
should we do this really it's it's not
worth it like it try to just avoid it
like in all possible like contexts just
avoid it all together because it's it's
such a rabbit hole especially I think
the more senior the engineer is the more
likely they're going to want to like
dive deep into this thing because it's a
it's kind of a cool problem it really is
and it looks at the surface layer it
looks like it's actually it's quite
solvable
um and it kind of is
um but it's going to be very very
difficult it's like uh just horribly
difficult so
um
oh yeah and uh besides that uh
this might be an obvious as well but
like when you're talking about protobuf
adoption uh generally adopting it uh
well you're gonna need to do it
organization-wide acceptance rate of
this entire thing and that's gonna be
kind of hard as well so
um but there are some times when you
might want to do schema Discovery and I
think the primary one is that you have
absolutely zero control like none over
where your data comes from and meaning
that maybe you don't have control over
the fact that like establishing this
source of truth if you have a Kafka or
something like that maybe you absolutely
need to have maybe there's only one
place where things come from forever and
you can't deploy anything new right like
maybe you have like I don't know
everything comes through an FTP server
and it has csvs on there and that's it
and uh because of the gov cloud or some
of some crazy rules whatever they have
like you can't deploy a Kafka you can't
do any of that stuff well then maybe
this is a thing that you should probably
maybe look into but uh even then I would
argue to say that it's probably better
to like try to figure out like finagle
your way through through this you know
and talk to the customer and be like we
kind of need this thing in here so
um
yeah and uh even then I guess that's the
final piece of this is that like even
then I think you should be wrapping it
in protobuf uh anyways like and by that
I mean uh you're talking about like deep
uh deep envelopes so basically you have
like an outside envelope that is
protobuf and then inside that there's
going to be a field which is just like a
byte array and it's and that one is like
who knows what maybe it's CSV I don't
know like it could be anything in there
and then you can pass that a little bit
further Downstream but at least you've
already you've established something
right that like there is some like
schema to like the data that you're
dealing with instead of just like
throwing it over the wall right so
um and uh I think it's probably it's
pretty obvious but but opting protobuf
um across uh uh in orgs it's
significantly easier to do it in small
works like way way easier because uh you
can totally just rip the Band-Aid at a
large org it always uh has to be
essentially like a piecemeal type of
adoption where you know you have one
server is that only cares about this
type of data and it's going to be
protobuf and then it's it's just a whole
massive juggling act and stuff so
okay I think that is it thank you very
much
I am Daniel sellins your host
talking about great things and by the
way listen
um from all this amazing knowledge that
you just got
this guy
um give a star to this open source
project called plumber okay it's a
basically a Swiss army knife if you ever
need to deal with like writing to uh
writing reading from Kafka to Rabbit to
gnats whatever every single possible
back end basically is there
um like mqtt or something like that you
would just uh instead of having to write
some throwaway code well just use this
to easily write to it and read from it
and that sort of thing and also has a
bunch of protov support in there as well
and Thrift I think as well so anyway
that's it done
foreign
[Music]